[Musique]
série les enfants waouh
vous avez mis le paquet là c'est un peu
trop
non couchés greg
[Musique]
écoutez ça des phénomènes mystérieux se
sont déroulés récemment à madison dans
le delaware
la ville a été envahie par les créatures
de manuscrits originaux de rl stine le
livre qu'elle livre c'est un chair de
poule
une serrure c'est pas vrai qu'est ce que
tu as fait
grand temps qu halloween est dure pour
toujours
ils ont pas l'air content attention
attendez une minute
on est en train de vivre une aventure de
chair de poule il paraît que c'est à
hurler de rire
les monstres d'halloween zombies ben
ouais c'est trop cool c'est vraiment ma
fête préférée
tu vas avoir besoin d'aller voir un psy
après ça
livre ses seuls moyens de les renvoyer
chez eux
c'est parti
et ben s'il ya un concours de
déguisement c'est lui qui gagne chair de
poule 2 les fantômes d'halloween
c'est des petits nounours